[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
guys and welcome back to another episode
of the lehigh pen show powered by the vc
firm icon plus capital and sponsored by
block five so if you don't know block
fight offer very competitive interest
rates particularly on bitcoin and stable
coins i use them i love them so if you
are interested then i'm gonna leave a
link in the description and in the
comment section i think you can get
around 250 when you sign up so pretty
good so today i have um a very exciting
guest um i'm in the middle of reading
his book so it's great just to speak to
him um and also with everything that's
going on in the world right now
particularly with inflation which we
found out is not transitory it's gonna
be great to speak with him so joining me
today is jeff booth entrepreneur tech
leader and author of the price of
tomorrow jeff great to have you how are
you great thanks for having me leila
yeah it's so good to speak with you i
think that especially during times like
this where we're seeing um
astronomical levels of inflation we were
told that it was transitory um it's
clearly not quite transitory i know you
have um some really interesting um ideas
which i really want to go into and i
kind of want to start with the premise
of your book which is essentially that
technology um and the price well
technology will essentially um
lead to
price deflation which will then cause
mass unemployment so i'd really like to
understand exactly what you mean by this
where does technology come into play
yeah so the overriding factor in the
world right now and what central banks
have been up for up against for a long
time
is technology is supposed to make our
lives
give us more for less which is
inflationary so that technology is
productivity
exponential productivity and if you look
at your phone or
or this this call we're doing
if you think about anything we do today
we're used essentially technology to do
it
and that technology what ends up
happening with technology is
is
that things move towards the marginal
cost of production which becomes free
especially with ai so if you a really
good example is
10 years ago 20 years ago think of
all the industries around camera
equipment camera sales film distribution
of it and everything else and how many
photos you took
yep compared to how many photos you take
today
and
and the cost of it entire industries are
decimated new industries are formed and
the new industries give you
way more for less
we take
trillions of photos how the photos are
driving part of our culture today and
it's all essentially free
the the photo the the camera on the key
on the iphone
is i think it's an under five dollar
bill of materials item today and it
produces 3d and everything else so so
that even that camera
10 years ago would have been
so so when you think about what happens
it just that that
that base layer of technology is driving
everything down in price as we're
supposed to be getting more
against that and that's why i said it's
been happening for a long time now
against that we have a system that can't
allow deflation
so our system that we live in is a
credit-based system
and that that
has to grow forever so inflationary
inflationary you have
essentially you have
we believe we need two percent
inflation
to survive
it's just it's not true
the the system that we designed
a credit-based system that doesn't
actually have hard money at the bottom
of it it's just credit
requires inflation to survive
so that
raises a very interesting interesting
um
quandary or it's it's it's actually the
driving force of every other thing in
the world today
these two things colliding into each
other
one man-made system that must
that must create inflation
against technology that's trying to
drive the other way
and so when you do that what ends up
happening is you concentrate wealth and
power in very few hands from then player
and you're picking the pocket of a whole
bunch of other people
and they're looking out of the world and
the things that
aren't being driven by technology
and there is still technology in it that
let's say housing or food hasn't
transitioned as fast as others or
education
education is free today people just
don't know it's free today yeah
but it's um but all of those industries
that are scarce go up in price and we
and a whole bunch of people that had
their pocket picks through inflation
can't afford to live anymore and they
rise up
and they vote for different leaders
who carry on the same type of tactic
because the exact
entire inflationary system would
collapse
without
wit without manipulation
so
why did why does that two percent
inflation have to have to exist why is
inflation necessary because because but
what ends up happening with an
inflationary monetary policy is and
let's say the reason that exists in the
first place
is
because then governments can give you
more service than they can pay for and
they can hide some of that
in inflation that nobody votes for
so it can expand government's powers to
essentially pick your pockets
um and and and because we will all vote
for people who will say
we would if somebody said
i'm going to tell you the truth here's
what it looks like and we need to go
into a deflationary spiral and every
bank will collapse and every institution
collapse would that person get elected
no and so
it so that's that's the point we all
believe
that we need inflation we don't it's
it's insane to think that inflation
it's insane just to think humanity
requires
um
a uh
a theft in their money
of course to live in a productive
society
it's just not true it's categorically
categorically not true what is true is
the system requires it and because
because when debt keeps on getting
bigger and bigger
inflation has to go higher to
pay back the debt because you can't pay
it back with taxes you can't pay it back
if you increase taxes if you if you
charge every company 100 percent taxes
next um
in the us
you couldn't put a
dent into one year
of what is needed
to run the run the budget
so
access can't solve it so you have to you
so you have to resort to playing tricks
and essentially funding in a different
way which is destroying currency
and hurting a whole bunch of people as a
result of that
it sounds quite um inherently um evil
and like it's sort of done by design do
you think that it is done by design or
do you think it's just by accident that
we ended up here
yeah
i i so it would be easy to think it's
done done by design and i think there's
there's a number of books out there that
uh that that would talk about by design
in the monetary layer
um
well that might be true in some senses i
don't think that where we are now is
done by design i think it's more
ineptitude and and understand and and
not understanding how a system feedback
loop works
that that system feedback loop making it
bigger and bigger and bigger all the
time requiring more debt all the time
requiring more
um and no way out
but but ask ask any policy
ask yourself if you were elected queen
of the world today
how would you fix it and how would you
fix it other than an alternative system
because the system itself can't fix it
because if you if you stopped if you
stopped inflating
if you allowed the free market to work
people would not want the free market to
work right now because the free market
would mean every single thing would have
a cascading collapse
everything every bank would fail around
the world you would have
no food on the street you're on shelves
you would it would look it would look
terrible
because we are so far past the point of
rescue on the existing system
so so what you could say policymakers
are trying to do and they're scared to
death and rightfully so
um is there
they have to
what ends up happening is when you have
corruption and money you have corruption
everywhere there's a result
and and so what they'd have to do is
oh look over here and create and create
more misinformation
to be able to keep printing
which hurts a whole
class of people but you have to ask what
would they do what it would so so
they're trapped right unfortunately
they're trapped right now and as a
result of them being trapped we are all
trapped
so there's so much there to unpick so i
want to start with the idea that if we
move to an alternative system you're
essentially saying that everything would
collapse banks would collapse would be
supply chain issues no food on the
streets um but
i'll get into bitcoin in a bit because i
know that you every tweet you end with
bitcoin you're obviously a bitcoiner um
so
how then do we how then would we even
move to a kind of world of hyper
bitcoinization if there would be this
serious collapse and i know that
bitcoiners don't really care necessarily
if there's going to be a collapse with
the banks right we're kind of almost
unbanked anyway they should care okay
explain
and they should care because
if you don't understand that piece you
misunderstand human nature and know what
human nature would do under those
conditions yes under those conditions
um we are very susceptible to
dictatorships controlling us and doing
really terrible things to other people
so every bitcoiner should care
that the existing system doesn't
collapse they should be voting for a
smoothie
in fact bitcoin smooth
transition
and that's that smooth transition
um as mad as they are at the existing
system as mad as they are
there are people in this existing system
that are that are terrible people
yeah
but there's also a whole bunch of good
people in the existing system
and and it's easy to
it's easy to turn against all people in
an existing system when you see the
truth and what's that existing system is
most of the what's happening in the
existing system
is just momentum that has to keep on
feeding back on itself and many people
have no idea
so how what would a transition look like
i look at bitcoin
i look at bitcoin specifically and
that's actually why i post quite a bit
i've looked everywhere for
for
understanding this problem what what
possible way what possible bridge to the
other side
uh is there and i've only seen bitcoin
it's the only possible bridge i've seen
i may be wrong
but but i've done investigation every uh
everywhere and i don't see another one
for a very variety of reasons
but when is it what the thing is
happening today is people are looking at
bitcoin and they're looking at bitcoin
through the lens of where bitcoin is
today
okay
and and
imagine in the u.s or canada or any g7
nation
that everything collapsed
could you use your bitcoin everywhere
and and that's the problem today you can
today it's hard
yes but
but what ends up happening with all
technology is people
project the current forward instead of
where it's going forward so the network
on bitcoin the network effect on
layer two on bitcoin
is making the roads easier and easier to
use bitcoin to be able to become a store
of value and to purchase with it
and so
i i use this example i've used this
example often in 1999 when when the when
the dot com market collapsed
the dot-com market collapsed
and amazon was trading at
under five dollars
and they were selling books and a couple
other items
what if in that time and and then the
writing was it was on the wall
that amazon was going to be this great
company i was an investor in it then i
saw what it was it was going to be this
great company writing was on the wall
then they're doing the same thing today
but
but what if every retail store collapsed
in 1999 and amazon wasn't selling books
you would see what what i'm talking
about the layer in the monetary layer
here right so what ends up happening is
a transition happens in the net when
one system builds
and it's getting stronger and stronger
and stronger and one system
flails and gets harder and harder and
harder to be able to use and as that
system starts to flail more and more
people see the new system and they walk
across the bridge to the new system
that's what bitcoin is
and as more and more people are walking
across the bridge
to to build the new system both in
holding bitcoin
uh yes the early people walking across
the bridge on more uh more or more of
the future have more say in the future
but all people walking across the bridge
make the bridge better and better for
everyone else and it's easier and easier
to use and so all the all the investment
and layer two all the all the technology
all all that
is essentially you could look at
yourself myself at this call us talking
to other people who will see this call
and and say i need to get off zero i
need to
understand bitcoin
and and you could see those people as
becoming nodes in the new in the new
infrastructure nodes in bitcoin
which make that
system stronger and stronger and
stronger over time if that happens at
the right rate
then
if i you if you looked at el salvador
today you could buy your groceries with
bitcoin
right you can so there's places in the
world that you can start to see this
transition happening it just hasn't it
just hasn't it it needs it needs more
time to move to the other side
okay so it's all about a slow transition
it's not as if tomorrow we can
essentially overthrow everything um the
the
existing system um so so let me just
clarify that too okay
i can't say what will happen because
when you have a system that is this
uh fragile
yes anything could happen um
said which snowflake causes the
avalanche
we got a lot of snow falling on the
avalanche um and uh on on
and and there could be a cascading
collapse any time there could be mat and
that cascading collapse would cause
massive more printing to try to stop it
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
fragility in the existing system so i'm
i'm telling you what i hope happens the
healthiest way right yeah yeah okay so
that would be the healthiest way um that
slow transition infrastructure slowly
being built so people can buy their
groceries but my question really is el
salvador got a lot of hostility from the
imf even the bank of england which is
laughable because of course inflation is
isn't in
unprecedented levels in england yet the
bank of england are focusing on el
salvador rather than themselves and the
imf the u.s so much um
hostility even christine lagarde and the
president of um the european um uh
central bank she basically said that
bitcoin isn't a currency so we can see
that the establishment really don't like
bitcoin they see the power that it has
so
how then is this go how is this
transition really going to take place
it's as if like let's say blockbuster
versus netflix you know what if
blockbuster were powerful enough and
angry enough to actually stop the
development of netflix
is that possible
so
so number one your question makes me
laugh because yesterday i put a
tweet out that said people in glass
houses
shouldn't uh made of manipulated money
shouldn't throw stones
right
your glass house of the world imf lives
in and everything else throwing stones
at somebody who wants freedom and a
currency that can't be manipulated
seems kind of ironic
um and and
so
but
but more important there is
every monopoly faces the same thing
um if you do the only difference this
time and is by the way it's a big
difference because we've always had a
monopoly of money
that we we haven't questioned
that it always will look like that
um monopolies in the economy and and
that question
look at other monopolies in an economy
and what ends up happening what ends up
happening is a monopoly
has its control through scale or
something else
and it it controls the access to that
monopoly and and few people are
privileged the monopoly is privileged
and most people are hurt by it
right any monopoly so what protects that
is those few try to
protect the walls and the end of that
monopoly what ends up happening is then
technology
lowers the barrier cost the access cost
so much so and produces so much benefit
that monopoly to to change their
business they can't change the business
because the access comes from delivering
value in a completely different way your
blockbuster netflix example or the one i
wrote about in the book is a good
example
because
the lowering of the cost of essentially
fiber and and video
meant nobody had to drive to a store to
pick up a video in fact you could in an
instant technology changed the rules and
invalidated blockbuster's business and
how did it do so it opened access for a
whole bunch of people who didn't have
access before
and so every technology does the same
same thing when you when you hit that
point in technology when you have kind
of a 10x value over the existing
infrastructure
the existing infrastructure can't
compete
so and and what ends up happening is
because way more of us way more people
are hurt by the monopoly than are helped
by the monopoly all of the people that
are hurt start using the new technology
or or all the other entrepreneurs that
say wow
i could never create a business over
here in this structure yeah and on this
new structure
and they and they go to build their
dreams hopes empower the future on the
new technology
so that actually that happens everywhere
from horses to cars
to to
to the printing press to to the compute
the internet every single thing looks
the same thing and a way and the
monopolies that used to stand before
were built on different rules and then
technology changes the rules that's all
that's happening with uh with that's all
that's happening right now um is
bitcoin specifically
lowered the barrier cost access costs
everything
else from the existing system
and a whole bunch of people that are
hurt by the existing system
are moving to the to the new system and
that that movement creates that bridge
across to the other side it actually
makes perfect sense that el salvador
would be on bitcoin before the us
because
the monopoly
and and just like it made perfect sense
that
no
no vendor that sold to walmart
was the first seller to amazon
it was all the people who couldn't it
was the 99 of products that couldn't get
into walmart
went on to amazon so it's it's just what
ends up happening with any technology
change
yeah land of uh the place of opportunity
the blockchain right now the land of
opportunity um but you did an interview
with um andrew yang which i was actually
so happy to see um because um i want to
talk about universal basic income
because he has this idea that um with
technology
um developing um people are essentially
going to be put out of work and we saw
that happen um at the time of the
century but um
essentially with technology speeding up
right now
the whole idea that people can simply
learn to code
isn't quite possible and so he believes
to sort of um i guess make that
transition easier we should have a
universal basic income so i'd love to
know your thoughts on that and whether
and how you think we would transition
bitcoin aside just in general with
technology moving forward the metaverse
and everything like that you know i
think i think engineers and developers
are one of the most sought after jobs
right now um so what's you know your
lorry driver going to do um when we're
all sort of living in the metaverse
yeah um keep reading my book by the way
um andrew came
and i don't think publicly he can say
this and everything else but he came on
almost a 180 from his belief pattern
before so he oh okay so we agreed
so he we both see technology and what
it's going to do and it's going to save
time and that saving of the time comes
as a result of jobs going away like we
could be we
here's the most kind of
big example i could say why don't you
pay for your oxygen
the air you're breathing right now
i feel like we kind of do
area breathing right now why don't you
pay for it um and and and it would be
ludicrous to create an economy where you
had to pay for your the area breathing
because the hair you're breathing is it
abundant is abundant right we don't even
think like why would we do that
well there are so many places that right
that that essentially technology is
going to create the same thing just like
just like so
um so it's it's moving everywhere and
what it means is things should be
dropping in price as jobs come out of
the market things should be dropping in
price at the same rate
the reason why basic income is is kind
of used as a fix
is because
you're having to you're pushing prices
up against the natural forces
and then people say i need money to live
and and it like and think about this
so i create more inflation so most
prices go up
and because house prices go up and it's
the only way people can escape it's one
of the only ways people can escape that
inflation blackstone starts buying
houses
and then rent and then rents go up
mm-hmm and open and and people can't pay
if people can't pay their bills so so
then government says wait i need to
create more inflation so i can give them
more ubi so they can pay their bills
it's insane
so
cause it's a cycle it's a cycle that
reinforces itself and reinforces itself
and a lot of people will vote for that
cycle because they're so hurt by the
system it's like a monopoly board going
around a monopoly board somebody has all
the properties
the properties they they get to keep the
properties forever there's this
injection making those properties more
and more valuable
and then a whole bunch of people that
are that can't get around the monopoly
board anymore and can't end the game
normally in the monopoly game would be
thrown out or the game would end right
people would break
um and but they can't get around the
board so so what the people in power say
instead of give them 200 when they pass
go we're going to give them 400 and push
the prices even higher
right so and then they can't get around
the board again and so that's what's so
when you look at ubi through that lens
that's what it is
and what it in
and
andrew after that call we've had lots of
sense and everything that's cool but but
he became a bitcoin advocate after that
call
because um and and but he asked me he
goes how many people understand bitcoin
like you do
like the the this is the
this is a transfer in systems
that that can allow humanity to flourish
on the other side and we need to get to
the other side of that that system
so so i have a lots of respect
especially lots of respect for somebody
who um
will
will look at the facts and change their
mind
um
and and so uh but but but he he and he
now understands bitcoin and why it's so
important he's actually speaking in the
bitcoin conference as well
oh amazing that's so good to be able to
um i guess orange pill somebody um
especially a politician um because i
think i think we need more people um on
our side but in times in terms of
inflation in general i think what really
concerned me was the idea that people
are um claiming that it was it was going
to be transitory um i think um the video
actually came out of the uk which was
saying um
that economists didn't expect it
um which is so strange because um i
don't have a any um finance degree or
anything like that i have a journalism
degree and yet i expected it right so
how do i how do i know that information
was going to come and things like that
but economists didn't so either
the economists that are um essentially
in charge because they obviously um
provide financial advice for those who
make who set policy um
either they're ignorant
or
there's something else going on here so
how did they not know yeah so is this so
do you remember that paul krugman
uh yes that says about that about the
internet the internet
it made no difference the facts machine
15 years later defending that quote
i didn't know he defended it oh i didn't
know that in a big way he defended it
and he said this which is way worse than
the original quote
i'm an economist i don't make
predictions on on technology
so so and why is that worse we have an
economy globally
that is more and more led by technology
all of it is technology
yet an economists think they're immune
from people making mistakes on
technology an economist that doesn't
understand technology
it can't be a very good economist by
definition
and and so
and and that's the that's the thing
that's so hard in these transitions most
people
most people we predict our future for
our existing path forward instead of
where technology is leading us it's very
hard to understand and so there's a
whole bunch of economists that are stuck
in that same loop
thinking they're playing by the rules
before and all their models are working
before as before
and they simply cannot work in the
techno and where we're moving with
technology it's actually this sim is
really this simple
technology moving at this rate requires
a currency that allows for deflation
requirement
if if and and that requirement is almost
impossible for an existing central bank
to allow
right
so but but
and i'm going to put a caveat on that
requirement it does it doesn't require
it if you concentrate all control in
central banks and and and the world
looks like the entire world looks like
china
very few people making decisions for
everybody else
um but if the world looks like that it's
not a world i want my kids to grow up in
but and it and so but it but where
technology is moving how fast it's
moving it requires a currency that
allows for deflation
otherwise
with inflation against that because
they're opposite opposing forces
otherwise you concentrate all all wealth
and enhance ends of you it's really that
simple
wow
so it's the
only thing
that i've seen that allow will allow
that transition
okay so
okay so just i'm really trying to like
understand it really it's just the it's
kind of just the
push and pull and the friction between
technology which is which is allowing
for deflation in prices because of the
abundance that it's creating versus the
the essentially the monetary system that
we have which is causing inflation and
then that those two together creates
this
centralized power and so so yeah exactly
and and you centralize faster and faster
and faster because the because because
technology is moving one way in the uh
opposite way
so so people that are thinking you're
going to have inflation forever
the minute the
government stop uh printing
you're going to have a deflationary
spiral
the minute and is and that's good
or bad so that would collapse the system
right right right right would it
collapse into that collapse with no food
on the street and everything yes yes yes
um
people us we would elect dictators to
fix it for us
there would be so individual rights and
freedoms would go away a different way
in if that collapse like that
without the collapse keep on printing
we elect dictators in a different way
and and so unfortunately there's only
door one
keep printing
um and when i say door one or door dude
or door two don't
and keep printing on the way there
typically looks like revolution and war
there's high likelihood that as you keep
going even in the u.s that you have
revolution um that
that
trickles over and everything else as
more and more people think it's
those other people that's the problem
when it's a system problem but
at a high level you have one or two
doors keep printing
um all of the negative externalities
from key printing don't keep printing
all the negative externalities
of that and and that's actually why the
system can't change itself it needs an
escape valve it needs this bridge to the
other side and so a lot of people that
are understanding bitcoin they're
starting to walk across this bridge
and the bridge is gonna and on the other
side it's really exciting
it's really exciting for the people
there's so much opportunity in the
ecosystem right now it's really exciting
for the but but this transition from one
system to another is going to be messy
so both doors lead to hell and
dictatorship essentially
unfortunately there is no okay
unfortunately there is no that's good no
that's a good thing
wow i would say yeah it is but it's
actually also why why in bitcoin many
more people i i know i know people do
care care about this but it's so easy
to look at an unjust system
and say those people
it's really
all of those people and there are people
in there that know the system's unjust
and and and gain from it anyways and and
and
um and will close their eyes to the
gains that they get
so
i understand how you could paint
everybody with a picture of a few people
um and say but most people in that
system don't know what's happening
so um i have so many questions
okay so how did you i'm gonna start with
this one first actually how did you land
on this realization um between deflation
and inflation um and how did you really
just realize before bitcoin that we
desperately need um an alternative
system and that both doors lead to
dictatorship and health essentially
um
i
i've always been um
this sounds arrogant no it's fine
i've always been able to see the future
in a way that other that very few my
friends could
that that because
because
um because i know how my own mind
changes and stuff as well and i'm not
always exactly right but directionally
it's what creates it's actually why i've
always been an entrepreneur and i've
created tons of value in understanding
how the technology the intersection
it's almost from asking this it's
why does the world look like this
when technology could create it to look
like this
and so if you just think through that is
what ends up happening is
um
all of our reality from our systems we
live in and the things we use are
actually ideas first
if you think about this this iphone
it would it was an idea that competed
with an idea of a blackberry that you
needed keyboard and when it first came
out
everybody thought it was a toy
everybody in using blackberry thought
that what a gimmick and everything yes
and look at it now but that idea
was just such a radical idea and by the
way in and if you think about the
evolution of that
at palm pilot which was almost the same
idea
didn't hit the right step of the kind of
the the intersection of when technology
changed the rules to be able to create a
better idea it was early and and it
failed
yes because technology opens up an
ability to do something totally
different
our minds change and we accept a new
idea and that new idea is really
exciting because it gives us so much
value
and so it explodes that's what i do in
business i do that everywhere in
business i've been quite successful in a
whole bunch of different companies in
business boards investments and
everything else
and and so
from that and and seeing all of the
different things in that i was working
on and
the leading edge of what's coming in ai
and 3d printing and and and all of that
i couldn't stop asking
why aren't prices going down everywhere
why prices weren't going down everywhere
like it was it was kind of a 10-year
question and i would talk about this all
the time all the time and i did not want
to write a book about it
but but i'm an entrepreneur i want to i
want to when i see something that
doesn't work i want i i have to figure
out to the bottom of it why not how
could it work
and
and so that's what led me to
to look at this
and then then i realized okay why
inflation is like this why it's needed
for the existing system
and but but when i looked at the last 20
years required 185 trillion dollars
of easing
to be
can we work to grow the economy by 46
trillion
essentially to to
when i said those angles one system is
moving this way and the other system
must
have the opposite effect so you have to
increase the amount of printing to
offset that over and over and over again
i could see the train wreck coming
and and in the train wreck and
i realized that
my family my kids wouldn't grow up in
the same type of world that i i did and
i i
and and i needed to write the book to be
able to explain that because it was
driving me crazy it was driving me crazy
that you had a whole bunch of technology
entrepreneurs on one side talking about
what they were going to do and how much
money they were going to make and
everything else
not being able and and and not being
able to put together the
you can't make that much money
if the free market works and the
prices come down like that money is
being a derivative of of of inflation
driving driving the monopolies bigger
and bigger and bigger so google bigger
so so
that's why i wrote the book i just i i
eventually i got mad um
i love that
good no that that's great you know i
think um we need this kind of education
um i think it upsets me that there isn't
any financial literacy in school um i
have my own theories as to why that is
which a lot of people probably share um
so i you know i i love
having these conversations um you know
books like yours which really just
hopefully wake people up and you know we
can try and move to a better system um
so how did you then realize that bitcoin
was the answer what year was that and um
talk to me about that transition because
a lot of people obviously think it's a
scam when they first hear about it they
think it's this weird internet money
that doesn't exist so um yeah yeah tell
me about your journey behind it so
i i wish i uh
so i was too busy in my businesses
to be able to take this bitcoin
seriously in the beginning um
and
bunch my developers kept coming to me
and saying you got to get on this it's
really important and everything else and
i still didn't uh didn't take it
seriously
um i was in bitcoin before i wrote my
book
but if you'll notice on the book there's
one paragraph on bitcoin um in the book
it's not a bitcoin book it's a
um and and even after i wrote the book i
was still and and am still
open to any possibility that could
change this system
to to so but what i realize what i've
realized and can
i'm still open
if there's a
but i don't see another possibility i
think to to to move to the other side
without revolution war reset
to and and if you had that you would
actually build an inflationary system on
top of the reset again just like has
happened throughout history
um i don't see a another
um
anything
that actually competes with what bitcoin
is to get to the other other side so so
that that journey to get there and and i
remember my book was written two years
ago
and it's everything has played out if
you just look at that book when it was
written and you think about what's
happened since
it's like it's like a road map for
what's happening and what happens next
as a result of uh
as a result of this so it's it's
hardened my position on on bitcoin i
think it's that important
yeah i agree um since the last two years
since cover started and
all this money printing my position on
bitcoin has totally been solidified um
even more so you said that there isn't
another alternative but you are open to
seeing you know if there is one you're
open to it you're open-minded which i
think is great but there are over 10 000
different cryptocurrencies of course
they aren't all the same we've got you
know let's just say
a nice top five um so what is it about
bitcoin which um really seems to be the
answer compared to all the other
different um cryptocurrencies what is it
about the technology that you really
admire that's hard to do in in in a show
like this and that but i'll i'll give
that a a
stab
the way that the system is designed to
approve for work and decentralization
um
people will not make a choice
to have a deflationary currency
because there's too much wealth and
power to be able to design as a
different system so us we won't make
that choice
and that's why the
the the
the
the decentralization essentially that's
driven into the into the protocol the
security proof of work
that that
that security is a feature that proof of
work is a feature of the system the
energy use and require it
for bitcoin is the thing that keeps it
decentralized
and it's a feature of the system
that
stops humanity from actually changing
the rules so that's that's a big big
part of it
now but let's just say okay bitcoin
versus ethereum so bitcoin
tries to win store value this innovation
and everything else and
and and it does so and it does so over
time and remember if
if bitcoin came out today and everybody
knew what it was today
and it was in its infancy
it would have been shot down
today today like so if it so if it came
out and it was
a small market cap and everything else
and it had this dream of being able to
do this regulators would shut it down
because now they know what it means
right
think about what's happening with the
imf when you think about what happens
with china when you think about people
are trying to shut it down and they
can't shut it down it's impossible
um
but but
in year two they might have been able to
bitcoin so you had this this evolution
and this this system that got hardened
and hardened and hardened before people
woke up to realize
that it's a redistribution of power away
from central power
to human humanity
and and and so
and and so now it it's it's far enough
along that that its heart is very very
difficult to stop
so now enter other alt coins and because
bitcoin was going after that
it let's the use ethereum as example
wow this is a really interesting
blockchain can do this and everything
else how do we make money
but that looks more like a company
making making money and we're gonna and
so so a small group of people
do a pre-sale a pre-mine and say
a world computer
and it's gonna be blockchain for
everything else i actually do understand
why ethereum would have a network effect
today
um doing nfts and everything else
but the design of the system
in fees
makes it less secure and you have to
central and you have to
have to centralize and you keep changing
the design of the system yeah
and you have to keep and and and it's
not just it is you keep changing it by
the people who control the system
and so
and and then altcoins underneath that as
fees go up on ethereum
it opens up
attacks from below on oh i can do the
same thing for less cost and you have
tons of different alt coins so i'm not
necessarily
against people making their own choice
on their free market investment they can
make advice and everything else the
i just categorically i don't believe
they have any value
in the long term i think what ends up
happening is the design of bitcoin kind
of on layer one
what ends up happening on layer two and
layer three
why do you need those other coins
i think everything starts to aggregate
to the winner because um because all of
those
all of those use cases can be designed
on something that's way more efficient
and reinforces the primary one
so
so it's not um i just think yeah i
wouldn't again i'm an investor in
technology lots of technology companies
and i i i tend to think
what would i what do i believe and what
would i put my money in and and
and set it and forget it
um i wouldn't do that on a whole bunch
of altcoins um in in bitcoin i can
easily do that
i love that um i love hearing those kind
of um arguments but in terms of just
the other side um of um
what we were talking about going through
those doors and reaching the other side
with a better system um how do you then
see it played out so do you do you
actually see a world where things are
denominated um in satoshi's um
so how yeah tell me how you see it and
also do you think that would see only
certain states certain countries
adopting this new technology or is that
just part of the transition how does the
future look is part of the transition
and so so
so what gives the us
dollar um strength
is besides kind of
using oil and energy through a war
machine to be able to price and oil in
u.s dollars
what what gives the u.s dollar
strength around the world is a network
effect that it's used everywhere it's a
common currency
everywhere
as that happens with bitcoin as more and
more countries users and everything else
start to do it and layer two with
lightning or liquid and
start to start to use that this more and
more people that's what i meant about
the network effect more and more people
the on-ramps the technology the
different things the use cases
it's way easier to use bitcoin and be
secure in bitcoin today than it was five
years ago
the on-ramps are way easier it's simple
and the ux and the design and there's
and so the innovation coming into this
ecosystem is bringing more and more
people in
that if i want to hire an engineer in
um in india
um without going through government
without going through a bank by the way
i i i it took three weeks one time to
get a six-figure wire transfer
about two months ago to india through
it's just a nightmare through the
existing system and all paperwork and
everything else i don't need to do that
anymore
i can i can hire anybody anywhere and i
can start trading with those those those
those people through a different
through an altered
network
um that network is in its infancy
but it's growing leaps and bounds and
more and more people are
moving onto that network which opens up
more and more so that's the transition
that we're
talking about
and states can't stop it
because because because people
everywhere where a state has tried to
stop bitcoin it's accelerated why yes
because because because they're
essentially screaming at you with a
megaphone that says
here's why you need it
yeah
i think it's so interesting and we saw
that happen with china
saw that happen in nigeria
all it does is either further
decentralize the network or it forces
people to end up trading um peer-to-peer
which was the initial goal in the first
place um so
yeah it's really interesting i want to
just move on slightly so i know we're
obviously short for time at this point
but i'd love to talk about
entrepreneurship because obviously
you've had um tremendous success um
especially with build direct so
i kind of want to understand um
firstly do you think that anybody can be
an entrepreneur
i think anybody can i just don't think
people are uh
geared uh towards it and i think and and
why is they perceive risk differently
so so they don't perceive risk of his
status quo
they think status quo is safety
and they perceive
so a lot of people would look at
entrepreneurs as these enormous risk
takers
i categorically just disagree
we're
because here's the way i look at an
entrepreneur at being one
i'm in i i'm i'm actually
i'm risk adverse
i just i see the risk in the existing
system
and i don't want a job in the existing
system where i have no control over my
destiny
and even if i go in over here and and
and under so that's actually why i would
chase down to the sand will this work or
not what will it take and because it's a
bet on yourself it's bet on your team
it's a bet on
what you have to do to change to create
the opportunity and so even if you fail
you come out of that learning with so
much learning that the next time it's
easier
and so um so i i think great
entrepreneurs aren't risk takers they're
asymmetric debt takers
that's such a good point um because i
remember years ago um
i was living in a country um and i loved
my job and i was so happy that the job
brought me to that country but the
company was failing and so i had to
leave the country and i was so upset
because now i didn't have control over
where i lived and it was from that
moment that i said to myself i can't
ever rely on an exterior party to
basically determine how my life is going
to look so at that point i was like no
i've got to make my own money um i can't
do that
so i yeah so i could totally get that so
a lot of people watching um are trying
to build in this industry in the crypto
space so what advice i know it's really
cringy but it has it is actually very
helpful what advice would you give
somebody who is looking to start
building um especially in the world that
we're living in right now um a lot of
people do feel that opportunity
opportunities are being taken away um
just given travel restrictions and
inflation and things like that so what
kind of words of wisdom would you give
someone looking to build right now
there's so much i wish i was younger
because there's something
right
there literally is um because as
any time there's chaos in the world um
there's system transitions
entrepreneurs um
are required to be able to move that
forward hopes dreams everything else and
on their hopes and dreams do we ride as
a civilization that's what ends up
happening
and and so
so when you look at system problems and
those system problems create a whole
bunch of pain for other people
understanding how you can fix that pain
is what an entrepreneur does and when
you when you do that in a way that
delivers tons of value the business is
bound to be successful now doing that
figuring that out is which market how
does it how do i do this how do i focus
but i'll give you an example of what's
happening today to so then existing
industry and you could use twitter's new
ceo you could
you could use google you could use
facebook you could use
our communication channels are getting
more and more controlled
and they're getting more and more
control and what ends up happening to
build these monopolies what ends up
happening is
you
you have to attract people who will
deliver let's use youtube as an example
people who deliver
different content to your system
which attracts users
and so people think it's attracting
users that's the trick it's not it's a
tracking contract providers
and then as more and more content
providers come in and they're and if you
think about how many hours of youtube
are uploaded a day and most of that is
not seen
what ends up happening is there's so
much competition to try to be
that found
and more users are attracted to the
platform
mm-hmm those platforms are monetized
today are youtube gets all the money
through advertising and these people are
essentially selling their souls through
advertising and they get one percent two
percent half a percent of the
advertising break
to be able to to
to meet a buyer
on layer two on lightning and what's
happening on on lightning that whole
thing will be reinvented and it will be
reinvented everywhere lots of other
opportunities but
that whole industry would be reinvented
in in that if content is the value
and most of the content producers are
getting very very little
value
then there's an opportunity
on a system that lowers the barrier cost
because because because google system
requires that barrier cost because it
was built on a different model
on lightning it lowers the barrier costs
and there's somebody that could come out
and say listen i need three percent to
run the business or five percent
business to run the business but 95 of
the value is yours
where do you think the content producers
would go
lightning and as you did that what do
you think if the content producers are
all going there where do you think the
people would go
and and and and that's and and so you're
able to recreate
a whole bunch of value by giving more
people value the change to change change
business that's just one example but
that example would be in a whole bunch
of different places on the new rails uh
commerce that are coming
so it's true when people say bitcoin
fixes this um you know we could start
actually seeing those kind of
decentralized systems on the bitcoin
network um you know youtube alternatives
and stuff like that yeah that's what i
expect to happen yeah that'll take a
bunch of time but once that network
effect starts to to to spin
it'll spin faster and faster and faster
amazing so what are you working on right
now is there another book in the works i
know you said you didn't really want to
write one
and
of course right now i doubt it i'll
probably put up free content rather than
the uh yeah and i do a bunch of these
podcasts to be able to get out
i'll never say never because maybe i'll
get mad again on something else but
um
but the
this is moving i think it's inevitable
and and people like you a whole bunch of
influencers in in this community i would
rather just take the message forward
um and and
and and build it i can just slide off in
the background
well i really appreciate you coming on
jeff it's been so interesting i'm really
excited to continue reading your book
where can people um follow you and find
your book
probably just best on on twitter uh at
jeff booth the book's called uh the
price of tomorrow why deflation is key
to an abundant future and amazon's
probably best spot for that
jeff i want to thank you so much it's
been such a pleasure and i want to thank
everyone for tuning in
thanks a lot
all right we'll speak soon and guys
don't forget to tune in next week for
another brilliant guess
[Applause]
[Music]